all right zach i'm coming your way first
because this is your first big role on a
tv show so two-parter for you on that
first what is something about hitting
the set of the wilds that made you think
to yourself like yes i got this i am
made for this but then on the other hand
what is something about what it takes to
make a tv show that required a little
bit of a learning curve
yeah absolutely i think that um this
sounds so silly but landing in australia
and being put in the two-week quarantine
very much like gives you the time to
really think about what this whole
journey is gonna be i would say that uh
there's there's a there's a when you
when given the option that we were given
and to be working with such incredible
actors and incredible crew and writers
and directors you can't help but feel
the energy from them and feel that you
know that you're in the best of hands
possible i think that they
especially the crew did such an
incredible job of kind of welcoming me
in and making sure that i felt
comfortable and with how the kind of the
shooting of everything went down i was
the first day of shooting the first day
of production and truly felt like a fish
out of not even water like it was a fish
out of the sea out of the largest thing
you could possibly think of but um they
were fantastic in making you feel really
at home and the thing that i needed a
learning curve of was um
learning how to walk and talk
i think that we
actors do auditions where we're about
here for about the majority of our time
and then bingo so you're gonna walk
there and say that line at the same time
it's like right i do this every day i do
this every day i just every day so yeah
i would definitely say that for sure i
very much get that all right and so for
you i know that music is a pretty big
part of your career and it was largely
the focus for you when you were first
getting into the entertainment industry
when you were younger so do you remember
when you know acting became an itch that
you really needed to scratch whether it
was an early guest starring role a
commercial that made a big impression on
you you name it hmm yeah i mean i've
actually been acting longer than i've
been making music that's not really like
known i guess
in the world but
you know they're both
just crafts that i feel very creatively
fulfilled in
and i think this is the i mean the wilds
is the first time i was able to actually
you know grow with a character and and
have an arc and be able to like you know
make decisions really um and it just
felt very creatively fulfilled and and i
was just like wow like
i love this feeling and
and uh being able to bring henry to life
was you know such a pleasure and
it's just so great with that in mind a
question for both of you now because i
feel this way about the entire ensemble
where
every single character feels so purely
your own like if any other actor on the
planet played these characters it would
not be the same so what is something
where you got the creative opportunity
to i don't know have some influence on
the wardrobe change a piece of dialogue
a certain quality of the character that
is purely your own i mean i think henry
is a very specific type of um
character i mean he he has his own vibe
and wardrobe and doesn't really
care about what people think necessarily
you know um and
i mean brittany
our our wonderful
uh wardrobe uh designer was like
so open to kind of just hearing what we
had to say and uh kind of let us do our
own thing honestly i mean she had these
mood boards of us before we even came in
and there were a lot of them were
pictures from our instagrams and like
was kind of like trying to like compare
it and like kind of bring some of us
into our character you know and uh yeah
i mean
she was really open with us and that and
that whole team was so wonderful and
letting us kind of do our thing also
aidan like your glasses too aidan like
that's like yeah i mean i came in with
my glasses that i usually wear
uh in life for like the past four years
and ended up wearing them in the show so
it was really nice
how about for you zach what is uh what's
some some of something you specifically
brought to raf that wasn't in the script
to begin with i think rob's physicality
i think that rob's physicality really
changes over the whole season you kind
of watch him especially again bringing
it back to the close like he he very
much his posture is very much hunched
over he's very much one that's going to
sit in the background and i think that
kind of of
discovering how exactly this guy walks
and talks very differently than my own
than myself
um i also think that
uh
we we really kind of figured out his
hair to make it just very much like
young and naive and just
looking for whatever he can in the world
so i think that yeah there's definitely
some of those um
costume elements that added to that most
definitely all right i'm putting up the
spoiler warning for the rest of this so
you you two can talk freely about
anything that happens in season two and
we will save it for the appropriate time
i wanted to ask you about the scene in
episode five where you do the welcome to
the black parade speech because it
delighted me to no end but that is
something that we've seen on screen
before so what was it like figuring out
kind of like the right tone and the way
to deliver it so i don't know we could
still have fun with something and it
could feel right for your character
uh yeah i mean just that song it's so
timeless you know being able to to sing
that in the show was like
kind of perfect and it felt very like
honored in a way because you know that
that's a classic i think i think it
makes a lot of sense for henry i mean
obviously listens to you know mcr and
then
bands like that in order to feel you
know be in this emo personality um
yeah i mean it was it was that is a
really fun scene and being able to you
know act with with rachel griffiths and
david sullivan was such a i'm such a
pleasure rachel's reaction to when you
start belting it out is just like
absolutely the perfect cut it's
excellent
yeah yeah
all right zach so for you i wanted to
know a little bit about your experience
working with sarah on your scenes
together what is something maybe you
appreciated about her as a scene partner
that helped bring something out of your
own performance that maybe you didn't
even know you're capable of i remember
we we got the scripts for one and two
when we were in quarantine and all the
boys that were in quarantine like hopped
on a zoom we were reading in real time
and uh right as we got to the end of
episode one
the zoom cut out because it'd been 40
minutes and so we're like oh my god you
know so we were like trying to read on
her own and try and get to the end and
so reading that for the first time i was
so excited that i was gonna be the one
to get to work with her and um i think
that was so cool about working with
sarah is i think we're both from the
theater and so i think we both kind of
take those um that theater training and
that that kind of mentality and that
teamwork to really kind of craft our
scenes together and i think what's so
beautiful about these two characters is
that they have such different energies
and yet when you feel when you're in
that room with them and you're in that
environment and that when she's
explaining what's going on it is just
this battle of what what what is reality
what is going on and um i think that
sarah is an incredible actor and getting
work with her just allowed us to play
and have so much fun and
really be able in between scenes be like
okay well that worked for me well that
didn't work let's try this and it was
just a really collaborative effort which
i loved they're making me leave i have a
million more questions for you guys you
are something else in this season i hope
you are very proud of your work thank
you so much for the watch thank you so
much have a great day